so when you see the word white what
comes to mind I talk about the word
white
privilege I think power access luxury a
rice some good some bad
can't be critical of or what but there's
a strong element of racism in water
Australia I think he is a Leah and Miley
Cyrus white is a way of being doesn't
always mean skin color it's a way of
thinking when I think about white I
think about maybe a group of people who
I would love to be in harmony with but
don't always feel like they feel the
same way towards me what run controlled
system not understanding they don't
acknowledge what has have been in the
past that I try to understand as well
they just push it off and say that it's
in the past
what I think when I see the word White's
first word that comes to mind would be
privilege arrogance naive so there's
just several things throughout the
course of history that white people have
taken advantage of not all of them are
like wallowing freely and shamelessly in
their privilege but it seems like the
ones that are typically male the further
away you get from white the hotter life
can be sometimes controlling figures in
my lifetime and my mother's lifetime as
far back as I can think on such there
are things that I have to think about
that they never think about that just
doesn't even cross their mind when I'm
called why it like feels like it's
dismissing another huge part of who I am
which is that I am in fact a person of
color they are the average person they
are just people in general I want to say
helpful but only helpful so long as it
benefits them a set of values wanting
equality without giving up any other
power I think privilege is really all of
it just the ability to be
seen as a person whiteness is a
construct it's in the best interest of
the status quo for people like a need to
identify as whites and sort of let my
Native American identity fall to the
wayside I'm still a Native American
who's walking around on the earth and I
just will not be if I'm not going to own
it I believe if you're white or black be
yellow right bubble
you
you